Ryan Reynolds interviews Ryan Reynolds
for GQ the Deadpool stars been given the
magazine's highest honor top corner
looks like looks like we got two beards
in the room three if you can't your wife
so GQ Man of the Year that's a big honor
you know I can't I can't think of anyone
more worthy yeah well it's uh what's he
doing you know what are you doing here
and though the video features a jake
gyllenhaal cameo this moment is all
about Ryan and he joins the men of the
year list with usain bolt and Warren
Beatty Gigi Hadid poses nude on a horse
for allure the shots reminiscent of a
photo shoot Emily Ratajkowski did
earlier this year for Harper's Bazaar GG
also takes on the cover this time
wearing clothes and opens up to the bag
about her problems that go along with
coming from a famous family the star
wants to debunk the belief that she's
only successful because of her parents
saying that she's always wanted to be a
model she tells allure I knew I wanted
to make pictures better I was obsessed
with photographers and where models were
supposed to fit in ladygaga covers
harper's bazaar explains how she spent
her time away from the spotlight before
release of her new album joanne she
tells allure i wanted to experience
music again the way I did when I was
younger when I just had to make it
instead of worrying what everybody
thinks or being obsessed with things
that aren't important